il ya très longtemps que j'avais
l'accord que j'ai la conviction que
notre chimie sachant court à sa perte
1971 l'avenir de la civilisation
industrielle était le sujet de cette
émission présentée par michel paula et
certaines prédictions n'était pas très
optimiste je crois pas la disparition de
l'homme sur la tête ce que je crois
c'est la disparition de l'homme
technique saurait taire parce que
l'homme technique détruit la nature
empoisonne l'atmosphère empoisonnée
raison des catastrophes climatiques mais
aussi économique responsable de
l'effondrement de la civilisation
industrielle
une théorie appelée aujourd'hui la colle
absolue et qui émergent en france au
début des années 70 à cette époque la
société de consommation est à son apogée
la crise pétrolière se dessine et
l'épuisement des ressources commence à
un type c'est ce cet équilibre entre
populations production ressources
espaces disponibles qu'il faut trouver
les trouver assez rapidement sinon nous
ne faisons pas ça nos fils nos notes les
prochaines générations devront payer
notre égoïsme aurelio pesci et le
fondateur du club de rome un groupe de
réflexion international réunissant
scientifiques économistes hauts
fonctionnaires et industriels tous
préoccupés par l'avenir de nos
civilisations en 1972 avec l'aide de
chercheurs américains
il publiait le rapport meadows un
document scientifique précurseur qui
alertait sur les dangers de la
croissance
cette étude a mis en relief les
tendances les plus inquiétantes de notre
développement et leurs interactions
la plupart de ces tendances sont d'ordre
exponentielle disent les auteurs du
rapport autre point inquiétant pour les
auteurs du rapport la croissance
démographique planétaire il préconisait
même une régulation des naissances
il faut construire un deuxième monde
seconde monde pour
abrité les nouvelles vagues de
population c'est un travail de
construction un gala ce que l'humanité a
fait des pluies de moyen-âge le rapport
meadows prévoyait l'effondrement de la
civilisation industrielle pour 2030 dans
une dizaine d'années donc aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de collabo log le voit
venir beaucoup plus tôt
[Musique]